27 de abril en España han pasado solo
cinco semanas Desde que iniciara la
primavera pero las temperaturas son más
propias de los meses de Julio o agosto
una tendencia que cada vez es más
probable este jueves y viernes serán los
peores días de este episodio de calor
que está mostrando termómetros de Entre
10 y 15 grados por encima de lo habitual
en esta época del año está siendo un
abril de récords Y eso en meteorología
nunca es bueno es posible que en estos
dos días se superen las máximas
registradas en los últimos 50 años para
este mes sobre todo en la mitad sur del
país donde rozarán los 40 grados de
hecho como se hizo ya en 2022 el
Ministerio de sanidad ha propuesto a los
gobiernos regionales de España que
adelanten dos semanas sus planes contra
temperaturas extremas que normalmente
entran en vigor el 1 de junio Madrid por
ejemplo ya lo aprobó el miércoles y
adaptará los horarios escolares para
evitar las horas de más calor además de
abrir un mes antes las piscinas
municipales
se estima que entre abril y septiembre
de 2022 fallecieron por exceso de calor
más de 4.700 personas en España país en
el que quizás también Tendremos que
cambiar el dicho Popular de abril aguas
mil este cuarto mes del calendario está
siendo el abril más seco desde 1961 año
cuando comenzaron los registros las
reservas de agua están al 41,9% y la
época del año más seca está aún por
llegar el país lleva en sequía
prolongada desde enero de 2022